et can confirm Mariah Carey and her
backup dancer beau Bryan Tanaka have
called it quits what is the most
romantic thing about Tanaka he seems
like a really romantic guy overall
romantic Mariah was all about Bryan when
we caught up with the superstar in
February but a source close to Tanaka
tells ET the relationship fell apart
about a month later that's when the
couple was dining at Le hot spot catch
and Mariah talked to the waitstaff about
how she's still very close with her
ex-husband Nick Cannon quote Tanaka was
extremely jealous upset and he stormed
off from the table most manage Elysee me
sources tell et Bryan was really only in
the relationship for the fame quote he's
always desired to have a music career he
was hoping to collaborate with her no
collaboration is coming though and
Sabrina won't be dancing for Mariah
anymore either I'm gonna do my own thing
I have like a 60 minute set the
superstar has an upcoming tour in the
works with Lionel Richie and she just
launched her own label butterfly MC
records where she's currently working on
a new album set for release later this
year
you